Điện Anh, Lều Vai Sau chăm Chịp đã xe nhằm mới, nhưng vừa tân ra sống này đã đổi sập cái sát lưu.
Đà nghe này, sẽ điện Lều Văn Lạc, uten dương đã phải tá tuận nhằm viết thân,
sau khi ngôi nhằm mỗi xây của anh bị đổi sập.
Được biết, tổng givy sẽ giúp tà nhàng này hết cần một tiền, trong đó có vinh sau chăm Chịp là tiền đi vai.
Thế các con cũng đi làm thời đục rồi, thì nguyên hồi đồ năm tờ cất định Lều Vai Hoan Sau chăm Chịp đồng định giúp nhàng.
Gưỡng nghĩ, đều bà buồn con sinh năng làm việc thì mấy năm sau sẽ trả hết nợ.
Tính không người nhà của xây sau đã bị chương vui.
Anh lạc đồ sốt mỏi, được biết để có được môi nhà hăng chăm này,
anh đã đi hấp tình làm người thực dây, chăm Chịp thì có tiền.
Để ủ sự bố, hai người con đồ của anh cũng chỉ vừa mối mời sau và mấy tảm tội.
Nhưng gần đây cũng xin gì học để ra cất tình phía bắp xin vào làm công ty.
Giờ đây, khi mà hai đều con đặc đi làm sao có chơi kìp về mừng nhà mối với bố mẹ thì môi nhà mối hăng chăm cũng chăm con.
Giờ đến cũng không biết thì nào mình có thể trả hết được của.